The Pamplona Bull Run attracts up to a million thrill seekers each year from all over the world,...
...hoping to combine the heavy-duty adrenaline fix with a hint of traditional Spanish culture.
But the reality of the Pamplona Bull Run is a far cry from the apparent fun...
...and frolics so often portrayed by tour operators and in the media.
Behind the festivities, there is a darker side, involving hideous animal cruelty.
The origins of the Pamplona Bull Run aren't clear,...
...but it may have begun in the 19th century...
...when local residents would run alongside the bulls as they were herded through the streets.
These days, however, the bull run has morphed into a huge tourist trap,...
...bearing absolutely no resemblance to traditional Spanish culture.
Many of the tourists are lured there by cheap package holiday deals...
...which promote the bull runners a boozy holiday with a difference.